a shootout between Henderson Police and
a man inside of a home ends with a house
on fire good evening to you at 11 I'm
Brian Loftus I'm Denise Valdez so that
suspect is in jail tonight and neighbors
are still coming to grips with what
happened Madison Kimbrough talked to
people in the area of Mission Hills in
Henderson and has our top story tonight
shots fired after Henderson Police got a
call about a suicidal man making threats
that man believed to be 19-year-old Mark
Ellsworth the Clark County Assessor's
website showing he was booked into the
Henderson Detention Center Tuesday
charged with first degree arson and four
counts of assault on a protected person
initially the caller believed to be
Ellsworth told police that he would
fight and shoot at any officers that
arrived and once police showed up to the
residents and found him outside that's
when investigators say things escalated
quickly the mill produced a long gun an
exchange of gunfire ensued officers
repositioned themselves
and encountered the mail a second time
which resulted in an exchange of gunfire
a second time eventually the man
surrendered with no injuries to him or
officers but during that time smoke
could be seen coming from the house Sam
and other residents who live in the
Mission Hills neighborhood of Henderson
say it didn't take long to notice all of
the commotion the fire was tremendous
and I heard him circling what is that
about that time my wife came out and
said there's something going on there's
a helicopter circling our house I ride
my bike passenger every day to go up to
Boulder City it's what I do for exercise
and as I came by there was a huge fire
over there and as you can see a lot of
a lot of response a lot more response
than I think for a regular fire it's
kind of odd fire officials don't know
what started the fire but the Damage
Done is severe in Henderson Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now
by the way Henderson Police say this is
the third officer-involved shooting in
their City this year